monsieur le président vous savez combien
je suis heureux de vous voir accompagné
madame bourguiba comme hôtes officiels
de la france heureux et honorés de vous
accueillir ici à paris il ya peu de
temps lors d'un nouveau passage
nous avons eu la possibilité de nous
entretenir longuement de tous les
problèmes qui se posent à nos deux pays
et nous avons vous et moi tracé les
grandes lignes de ce que doit être la
coopération dans tous ces domaines
politiques économiques techniques
culturels mais aujourd'hui c'est bien
autre chose c'est la france toute
entière qui vous reçoit et qui a
conscience de recevoir un homme d'état
au sens plein du terme c'est à dire un
homme politique qui à la tête de son
pays et par delà les problèmes
quotidiens
c'est guidé son action en fonction
d'objectifs d'envergure et pour tout
dire long sous le signe de l'événement
mais dans le cadre de l'histoire aussi
la france est elle heureuse de vous
accueillir
comme si je peux employer une expression
célèbre le plus illustre des tunisiens
est l'homme qui depuis 16 ans que votre
pays a accédé à la pleine indépendance
n'a cessé de travailler pour construire
un état moderne tout en préservant
l'essentiel est le meilleur les vertus
traditionnelles
c'est cela qui vous vaut l'estiment
général mais pour la france je puis vous
le dire
cette estime est profondément pénétré
d'amitié comment pourrait-il en être
autrement
s'agissant de la fin
ans et de la tunisie et de vous monsieur
le président qui tout au long des
événements parfois difficiles comme il
était et évidemment prévisible dans le
monde en bouleversements qui a suivi la
grande guerre mondiale avait su comme
les dirigeants français toujours
préservé l'essentiel et permettre ainsi
la permanence d'abord le développement
ensuite de notre coopération
aussi s de tout coeur que je vous
exprime avoue hammam bourguiba à tous
ceux qui vous accompagnent les voeux les
plus chaleureux de bienvenue roland du
gouvernement et du peuple français
[Applaudissements]
explique
monsieur le président
que pour la première fois la tunisie
rendent officiellement visite à la
france que pour la première fois l'état
tunisien viennent s'inspirer directement
de l'action de l'état français comme moi
même personnellement je viens dans ces
conditions aussi amical si solennel
m'entretenir avec le chef de l'état
français avec vous même monsieur le
président qui prolonge et les grandes
traditions françaises de culture
d'humanisme de dignité et d'indépendance
voilà qui me touche profondément
comble de joie n'ont pas pu donne à
notre rencontre
une signification particulière étant
donné la conjoncture et la situation
spéciale de nos rapports
les paroles empreinte de délicatesse et
d'amabilité que vous venez de prononcer
à mon égard souligné tout cela en des
termes émouvants
ma femme et moi nous vous en remercions
très sincèrement ma femme et moi sont
très émus de ne trouver en ce moment vos
hôtes dans cette ville prestigieuse dans
ce haut lieu de la grandeur française
le président cette visite officielle en
france constitue pour moi plus que la
réalisation d'un voeu cher la
signification
la preuve que j'ai enfin gagné mon pari
celui de substituer aux liens de
dépendance des liens de civilisation des
rapports de coopération active et saine
parce que librement consentis il s'agit
en effet de la consécration du caractère
exemplaire les privilégiés de notre
nation pour lequel j'ai sacrifié ma
jeunesse ma santé dans une lutte qui
aura duré un demi siècle cette visite
que lever à nos yeux une grande
importance sur laquelle nous fondons en
tunisie de grands espoirs
nous fûmes est rare heureusement
l'occasion non seulement d'envisager les
moyens les plus appropriés pour
intensifier notre coopération dans tous
les domaines de resserrer nos liens mais
aussi d'échanger nos vues sur les
problèmes qui nous préoccupent de
concerter nos actions en vue d'éviter à
notre région les malheurs de faire de
cette méditerranée qui nous a enrichis
de ces messages un lac de paix un lieu
de rapprochement et de coopération entre
les pays riverains sous le ciel de la
complémentarité de la solidarité des
intérêts c'est dans ces conditions que
je me permets de vous remercier de
nouveau pour l'accueil chaleureux pour
vous nous avez tous en france sur le
président messieurs nous avait accordé
qui s'adresse au delà d'un rébus
personnes au peuple tunisien pour
l'amitié avec le peuple français ne
s'est jamais démenti quelles que soient
les vicissitudes par lequel ils sont
passés merci
[Applaudissements]